I had to think very very hard about
these topics right and in particular how
I was going to sequence them in a way
that made sense right they say that a
good story has a good beginning middle
and an end and I think a course is very
much like that so for that reason for
very long time at that yes now I think
the topic we should leave you with is
this one okay now it's not what most of
you said which is which is fine that's
okay I'm looking forward very much to
getting into the paradoxes topic but the
reason why I think we should start with
really in mathematics is like this okay
why would why we doing this subject
what's this course about it's about
appreciating mathematics it's about
seeing it in places that you're not used
to seeing it normally okay now I think
you know the wider world out there
actually does really benefit from
mathematics and and see it everywhere
they just a recognizer right and we
don't get much time in regular masks to
divert you're saying can you see where
it is so when I say we did not manage
and that's kind of I mean two things
number one really itself media talk is
mathematical I think at its core when
people say this is aesthetically
attractive or I think this looks really
good okay even though they may not be
able to articulate it they're actually
touching your mathematical reality
that's there okay and I'm going to try
and equip you to see that a little bit
the second thing that I mean under this
topic is that the reverse the converse
is also true
mathematics it's beautiful it has its
own kind of beauty to it I had some ways
this is kind of a broader thing I hope
you're trying to show you this for the
next six months really and this is a
particular focus but I mean both of them
together okay
now underneath that we're gonna make a
subheading before you write it I just
want to share a quote with you I don't
know who write this point you can
probably I've said this quite you
probably find it a little knowledge is
dangerous
it's very dangerous a little bit is
anyone had this quick before you would
recognize it that's what's fine uh I
wonder how he met for the first time
most of you this morning what do you
think it means what do you think it's
talking about whyme right a little
knowledge be dangerous these suggestions
yep okay quit right sir yeah yeah so you
got a couple of different ways at the
earliest of my paraphrase understand
this quickly um if you're not very
clever you don't have much knowledge
that's a dangerous sort of thing right
in addition to that you know even a very
small piece of information can be very
powerful that's true okay are you gonna
say something
yeah yeah okay all right good all right
now I think those are both hell points I
wanna drive home on this word here right
why is that a little knowledge is
dangerous this is actually very very
learning from you guys I'm not gonna ask
you who this represents but I know a big
number of people and statistics tell me
a large number of people in this room
will learn a lot of things that they
learned in school they'll learn it ahead
of time right whatever context it is
very visionary or maybe it's or a friend
or something like that and the logic
particularly maths is if I meet it in
advance that would be really helpful to
me later on right when I made it again
properly in class I'll be familiar with
it and it'll be all right okay but I
think there's a lot of danger in them
okay because you sort of understand it
and then when you get to meet it's the
proper time you're like I do this I get
this right and so you pay less attention
to it you become kind of complacent
about it and you don't develop a realize
any of it you've never progressed from
that little knowledge that you have so
somebody I'd like you to make it is the
golden ratio now I know that you have
met this before at least you should have
sure that if you did it that's okay
today or just beyond with you right but
assuming you have you're like I think
I've heard of this kind of thing before
you should know a little bit about it
the most dangerous thing you can do
today is to say I know this this why are
we spending time inside come on
I chose this because it's gonna be
challenging a new right why are we
looking at something oh well maybe you
don't know it as well as you thought
okay and this is one of those classic
examples of what we talked about in the
last lesson which was a simple thing
which you can think very deeply about